lebron james and anthony davis pay
tribute to Kobe Bryant with new tattoos
the Lakers documented their new matching
Inc on Thursday it appears to be a black
mamba which was Kobe's nickname as a
black mamba it's been four days since
Kobe's passing on Tuesday LeBron broke
his silence on the tragedy sharing a
series of photos on Instagram writing
I'm not ready but here I go
I literally just heard your voice Sunday
didn't think for one bit in a million
years that would be the last
conversation we'd have LeBron also vowed
to carry on Kobe's legacy writing it's
my responsibility to put this on my back
and keep it going Kobe's final posts on
social media shared the night before his
death raised LeBron for surpassing him
on the NBA's all-time scoring list when
it came time to write the final chapter
of his NBA career
Kobe saved one of his most unforgettable
performances for last
[Music]
sixty
six zeros man
to spend 20 years here you can't write
something better than this on Monday
Anthony Davis wrote that Kobe was the
first guy to take him under his wing
quote had so many great combos about so
many things and I will cherish those
moments forever Bryant and his 13 year
old daughter Gianna were among nine
victims who lost their lives in a
helicopter crash in Calabasas California
on Sunday morning in wake of the tragedy
the NBA postponed the Lakers vers
Clippers game a source told ET quote
it's not just the players hurting Kobe
was here for two decades and is like
family to everyone in the building
no one is okay the source adds the team
brought in grief counselors who will be
available to employees and players for
the foreseeable future beloved by fans
around the world Kobe Bryant had
transcended the game he embodied
excellence achievement and aspiration
for millions of fans everywhere
[Music]
[Applause]